[Music]
britney spears's latest dance video has
a very
intentional soundtrack go um put on your
favorite pair of shoes
the pop icon showed off her new pair of
sneakers dancing to foster the people's
song
pumped up kicks
[Music]
in a lengthy instagram caption brittany
explained the shopping spree was due to
a shoe emergency
here's a brief recap last week britney
posted quote
this conservatorship killed my dreams
and in her new post she began with quote
so what do you guys do to keep your
dreams alive brittany went on to express
frustration at her apparently dwindling
shoe collection
a big problem as she claims to dance for
three hours on an average day
in response brittany said she quote
pulled a carrie bradshaw
and ordered a new batch of shoes online
against her assistant's advice
i was in the neighborhood i thought you
might want these back
with some new kicks in her closet
britney said quote my feet are soaring
these days
later in the caption brittney let fans
in on another dream of hers
hitting up a popular celebrity getaway
with a fellow music legend
britney says she's thinking about
visiting sandro pay with cher
and eating ice cream she then gave a
shout out to jennifer lopez's new music
video
cambia el paso
brittany says she's thinking about
having a six-pack like j-lo
an added quote lord she's so inspiring
in her new video
in brittany's bombshell testimony last
month she referenced her desire to drive
again
claiming she's been unable to do so
under her conservatorship
the singer was recently spotted driving
in los angeles
brittany even voiced her frustration
about this all the way back in 2008
the year her conservatorship was put
into place i love driving my car
something about being able to drive your
car that allows freedom
[Music]
and i haven't been able to drive my car
that's a bonus scene from the
documentary britney spears for the
record
where she touched upon what the everyday
act means to her when did you last feel
free
when i got to drive my car a lot on
monday et was outside the los angeles
county courthouse with brittany's new
attorney
matthew rosengart who gave a brief
statement to media outlets and the
gathered crowd of britney fans
i once again want to thank britney
spears for her courage
and for her strength i also want to
thank britney spears fans and supporters
outreach and support for my firm myself
and most importantly brittany has truly
been overwhelming
finally and the last thing i'm going to
say about
this matter is as i said in court
last week and outside my firm and i are
moving
aggressively and expeditiously
to file a petition to remove jamie
spears
unless he resigns first thank you
you